[Music]
hi i'm carly sirk and this is really
news now
i gotta say patriots we live in a very
concerning time
i'm not sure if you watch the woke super
bowl last night but if you didn't then
take it from me
it was an absolute flop
the thing that i found most offensive
was the halftime show and if i'm being
honest
it made me feel uncomfortable
and if i'm being truly honest
it made me feel uncomfortable
privately
this type of display should not be
allowed on television
women dancing on stage and exposing
themselves for our entertainment and
pleasure
this is neither american nor like a
christian these musical artists unleash
what i call sexual anarchy into the
homes of millions of innocent super bowl
viewers on sunday
on a sunday of all days really the
lord's day what does this world come to
well folks it's simple
anarchy leads to communism in a chaotic
decline of society ergo if you have
sexual anarchy then that would
ultimately lead to the chaotic decline
of the nuclear family the thing that we
hold so sacred the true measure of a
successful person in this country
so tonight when you go home to your
loving family i want you to sit down
with your spouse and your children and
discuss the evils of the nfl
because it's time we once and for all
banish the grotesque and unfair leak
from our american society
thank you and god bless